hi welcome to swiss biosciences webinar
on sequencing stars kobe 2 and
identifying variants of concern
for those of you who may not know swift
was recently acquired
by idt we're very excited about this
transition
where we can offer a wide variety of
support
uh and competitive pricing for our
customers
my name is jordan rusfigura and i'm the
director of materials sciences
at swift biosciences swift offers a wide
range
of products for ngs applications from
genome
sequencing to epigenomic sequencing
rna sequencing and library normalization
today i'll be talking about our targeted
sequencing specifically our excel
amplicon panels
and our swift normalized amplicon panels
also known as our snap panels
the last year has been hard on everyone
with the
coronavirus pandemic and surveillance
of sars cov2 and
finding new variants and tracking
lineages
is of supreme importance in our new
world
the swift normalize amplicon panels snap
panels
are a efficient and easy way
to do this the snap workflow
consists of going from dna to
a sequence ready library
it involves a multiplex pcr step
followed by adapter attachment and
indexing pcr
at which point you have sequenceable
libraries after that and included in the
kit
are the reagents for normalize which is
optional
and i'll be discussing that more later
the sars cov2 genome is
an rna genome of about 30 kilobases in
length
the swif the swift sars covi2 extended
genomic coverage
panel uses this roughly two hour
snap workflow and covers ninety nine
point seven percent
of the sars cov2 genome this is done
with 345
overlapping amplicons that have an
average size of 150 base pairs
as an input material it uses first or
second strand cdna
and we validate it down to 10 viral
copies
swift has available 384 cdis
384 udis and we're looking to increase
that udi
multiplexing capacity very soon
our kit is flexible for reverse
transcriptase
kits most people just make the first
strand cdna
and go straight into our multiplex pcr
um we there's a wide variety of
compatible rt modules
as long as they're using random primers
and has a processivity greater than a
kilobase
here i'm showing an igv shot of
the results from our panel covering
the full sarskov2 genome
in spring of 2020 so last year
we initially launched a version one of
this panel
and then in the late summer of last year
we launched our extended genomic
coverage panel
which filled in a few gaps in coverage
and extended the coverage on the five
prime and three prime ends
the data i'm showing here is from a
nasopharyngeal swab
where the library was generated with the
snap sars kit
and sequence on an aluminum iseq
this r assay is very flexible and
supports
a variety of applications and sample
types
it can be used for viral surveillance
waste
water epidemiology
variant calling and sample types that
it's been
successfully used with include nasal
swabs
stools and sputus
we've had a lot of great partners we've
worked with on the development of this
panel including dr adriana higuay
nyu who
was able to early on in this pandemic
track a variant of interest uh in this
small study she used 29 nasopharyngeal
swab
specimens and was able to find this
a to g transit variant
and use that to track the phylogeny
of samples around the globe and see how
this d614g
allele spread
we have validated this kit across a wide
variety
of viral copy numbers this is dated
made at swift uh using a
synthetic source code v2 control in a
background of human uhr
right and we were able to get a
very effective uh percent read alignment
that didn't change with read depth the
datum here
it show is shown for one million reads
in purple
and fifty thousand reads in blue we are
also able to get
uh faces greater at than 10x coverage
uh at very high amounts um
this does drop off at the lower viral
titers
um so one thing swift did
when we launched the version two of our
panel
was also develop and include uh cycling
recommendations
uh to optimize data at the lower viral
titers
so and what this data did it's the same
workflow just changing the cycling
conditions
and it you can see that it very much
crea increases
uh the percent freeze aligned and the
coverage
at the low viral titers so the
low input protocol is shown in purple
while our standard condition
is shown in blue we recommend this low
input protocol
for samples with less than about a
thousand viral copies
so but here i'm showing data for a
million viral copies
and a thousand viral copies using the
low input protocol
to show that we have very robust
coverage um
over a range of viral titers so
this is an igv shot of the whole stars
cov2 genome
with you know zooming in honestly
on a range so you can see the coverage a
little more clearly
right we have very good coverage
uniformly very good coverage with a
million copies
and that is still robust at a thousand
copies
um this data was generated using the bei
uh irradiated standard
and sequenced on an aluminum miniseq uh
with two by 150 paradigm sequencing
as i mentioned earlier uh the sars cov2
panel has an average of 150 base pair
amplicons
this smaller amplicon size makes
this assay very robust for a wide
variety
of samples including damaged or degraded
samples
there's been a couple papers recently
using our kit with waste water
including this paper
from asu that used
our kit to determine lineages in 91
wastewater samples
and they were able to sequence samples
and determine the lineage for example
with cts up to
35. so we're very excited by this we
think it's
very important work and you know she
really shows the power
of the snap stars kit
related to waste water we had some
inquiries
about whether we could make a panel
that sequences just the s gene this is a
way
to sequence uh the s gene and get
you know really deep sequencing to look
at subpopulations
without spending a lot on your
sequencing reagents
so the s gene panel covers a hundred
percent of the stars cov2s gene
with 43 amplicons it is the same
workflow
as our full genome panel
it just requires less sequencing
so here is an igb shot showing our
comprehensive coverage
of the stars cov2s gene we have 100
100 coverage of it um this data was
generated with a million copies of the
vei standard
and here i'm showing a dot plot where
each amplicon in the panel is
represented by a blue dot
the blue line on crop on the top is 5x
the mean coverage
while the red line is 0.5 x the mean
coverage
and as you can see we have a very tight
um
coverage uniformity in this panel
swift has also tried to support our
customers
by developing data analysis tools
or our ampcon panels
we have a uh
analysis pipeline available as an
open source 2 tool it is dockerized
and there is demo data available
we suggest you can go to the website
shown here
our data analysis tool performs primer
trimming
alignment with bwa followed by
primer trimming with primer clip which
is a tool developed by swift
specific for our one tube overlapping
amplicons
it then generates the pipeline then
generates on target
and coverage metrics and then performs
variance calling
we have a tech note for our sars kobe 2
dockerized data analysis i'm showing it
here
and this is just another workflow to
show
what this pipeline does um one
one thing that we have added specific
for stars cov2
is consensus calling so our pipeline
generates
a consensus fast day
and also gives a report on very
variant designation using nexclade and
pangolin
next i wanted to talk a little bit about
the
swift technology that allows
a one tube multiplex pcr and the
benefits that can come with it
so if you have overlapping ampsicons in
a single tube
they can create a variety of species i'm
showing a cartoon here
just showing two overlapping amplicons
where the primers are shown as arrows on
the top
right we have two sets in the first one
in blue
and the second one in purple these can
create
our intended what we call intended
amplicons shown on the bottom in blue
and purple
they can also create a super amplicon
where
forward one in blue and reverse two in
purple
uh interact and form what is almost a
double sized
con there's also many what we call mini
amplicons where forward two
and reverse one interact and form a
short end con
now if you just took target specific
primers
that made overlapping amp cons and threw
them in a tube that
mini amplicon could very easily take
over your data
because of its size it pcrs up much more
efficiently
part of swift's multiplex technology is
that
we stop that from happening so what i'm
showing on the left is a cartoon
which which is representative of data
you might get
if you just threw these primers in a
tube
on the right i'm showing data you know a
cartoon of what
much more representative data from swiss
multi-click
technology you don't want these mini
amplicons because
they don't give you as much data they
can over cluster a flow cell
and it's just you know a waste of freeze
here i'm showing some actual data this
is from
swift's 56g panel
where i'm showing two locuses in pix3ca
one where there are two amplicons that
are overlapping
this is on the left and as you can see
there we see the superanticons on the
top
the intended amplicons and then just a
couple of mini amphicons
but they definitely have not caused a
problem in the data
on the right uh we're showing amplicons
that are neighboring
so they're not overlapping and as you
can see we still see the super amp cons
on the top and the intended amps cons
but no mini ampicons are formed
so just to back up again to this now
that we've dealt with the minneapon
uh issue to back up to what can
overlapping primers bring to your data
so in either a one tube
or two tube solution swiss biosciences
has a one tube solution
where we form this super amicon
you will get overlapping primers in a
two tube solution
this super amplicon won't form and
that's because reverse one
and four sorry forward one and reverse
two
are in different two right so there's no
super amp con
and you may be thinking jordan why do i
care
well i believe that the super amicon
actually brings important data and is a
good nice feature to have because
what happens if a variant occurs under a
primer binding
site there are new variants
all the time for sars kobe 2 and
it isn't viable for all labs to be
versioning their primer set
every time a new variant occurs
so what happens if a variant occurs
under a primer binding site
i'm showing a variant as a red star here
and uh
and it's occurring under uh
the forward two primer so that's
been grayed out it's caused this
whatever this variant is it's causing
cause the loss of motion that means that
that purple
intended amphicon can't form
right because the forward primer is no
longer functional
you will still see that variant in
either a one tube or two tube solution
because it will be covered by the
neighboring
intended amplicon shown in blue here
but what happens to that coverage uh
over on the right of this slide what
that was covered but that was
covered by the purple anticon initially
well if you have a one tube solution
that creates a super amplicon
you will not only also see that variant
in the super amplicon
you can attain coverage using that super
amplicon
and maintain full genome coverage
um the uk variant is an excellent
example
of a case where this has happened
um the deletion 11 28
8 to 11 29
6 occurred in our assay
under a pre-existing primer site but
and you can see that in the data that
i'm showing here this is igb
the target regions are shown in the
lighter blue on the bottom and the
primers are shown in
dark blue so you're seeing that that
deletion happens right at the three
prime
end of this primer primer on the left
so but in our data we can see that
deletion clearly
from the uh targeted region
but we maintain coverage even though
that primer is not functional because
it's through prime and cannot bind
so how do we do that with the super
amplicon so i've just
zoomed out in this igb shot of it
so you can see that deletion kind of
right in the middle of the igb
shot and you can see that there are
super amplicons
um through throughout the data
and that's where our coverage comes from
so we think that having this overlapping
amp con one-two solution
is very powerful for
discovery of new variants and adding
robustness
in the presence of variance
so just to change gears a little bit
i promised that i would talk about
normally and i will do that now
the normalized technology is specific to
swift
and it is viable for a lot of different
assays most of these swift kits
have normal a's as an optional workflow
so in snap
the normalize portion is as i said is
optional
and occurs after indexing pcr so you
have
live full libraries that are sequencable
and you can normalize them if you choose
to
the normally workflow is
very straightforward it involves a
normalized one step
equal volume cooling of all the
libraries
so it really lends itself to high
throughput followed by
normal h2 that occurs on that library
pool
and then an inactivation and after that
you can take these this library pool
denature it and stick it on your
illuminant instrument
right how how part of how this works
is that it normally is one uh it is a
selection step
at that point uh you then take and pull
all your libraries
so showing here it's all in one bar
because all the libraries are together
and then in normalize two only the
molecules that were selected
are represented in your final tool this
is with
um a really great fast technology it's
easily automatable and it really
improves
the read depth uh variation so cv
coefficient of variation within a pool
which allows for savings on cost of
sequencing
so here i'm showing some data of showing
an improved index balance
between normalize and qtcr so what we
did
was we
made normalized libraries all these
libraries
were above the required
yield minimum shown in a green line and
we
pooled and sequenced them based on qpcr
that's shown on the right where we got a
cd of almost 24
uh we then took the same libraries uh
them and sequenced them and got a cv
of slightly less than six percent so as
you can see
you get much more even coverage on a per
library
basis with normalized chemistry
in addition normally it has the added
benefit of
mitigating index hopping on patent flow
cells so the data i'm showing here
is on from an ic and
you can see that libraries uh
were were all on a per read
uh basis equally identified but that
without normally
uh the index hopping what index happened
was present
shown as shown as the purple dots but
when you add normally
that's on the left uh index hopping uh
goes drops down to almost uh
unmeasurable levels so that's just
really an added benefit to swiss
normalized chemistry
next i wanted to talk about resolving s
gene dropouts
in coven 19 samples
so to look into this
uh swift worked with gene markers
that's based in lansing michigan
and identified eight samples from
kalamazoo
these samples had were uh s gene target
failures
right in the in their pcr assay it's
known that the techpath
assay uh can can have s gene dropouts
with the uk variant so we collaborated
with gene markers to identify the
lineage of each of these samples
um we used both the snap sars kobe 2
and the s gene panels just to try to see
like what depths do we need
looking and looking at real samples um
we assumed that all these s s gene
dropouts were the uk variant
v117 right but what we found was that
sample 8 was actually an unexpected
variant
so i'm going to discuss that a little
more
but i think this really shows the
importance of sequencing
because working on the assumption that
all the s gene dropouts
were the uk variant would have resulted
in misreporting for this variant
and that can complicate disease tracking
and all sorts of things
so looking at
the data we're able to see
that so what i'm showing here is two of
our other samples of the first two igb
tracks and then sample eight as the
third igb
track and you can clearly see that
deletion
69-70 on the left
is present in sample eight but
deletion y one four four is not observed
in
snap light and that was one of our first
indications
that this sample was not the k variant
this this variant again our sample 8
again
didn't have n 501 y which we know
is an important mutation um
there was enough depth at that
uh locus in sample eight for appropriate
germline variant calling
but it was all wild type we did not see
the n501y which we saw in the other
uk various samples
in addition um there were other
mutations observed in sampling that were
not
known uk variant uk variants and were
not seen in the other samples
so what was this sample a
ended up being b1 375
which is not a variant of concern right
so and i'm showing here a phylogeny map
from next clade
and you can see that red dot is
is sample eight right
um and it you know and i think this just
again brings home
that this could have been misreported
based on the pcr results alone
but that sequencing really made it clear
what this sample was and what it wasn't
so swift uh just to wrap up
swiss is really focused on empowering
um data right
by sequencing we also
in in addition to our snap sars
assay we also have rna kits
um if someone's looking to do rna-seq
we can we can
make libraries from as little as 10
nanograms of total rna
our swift excel and gs methyl seek
product can unlock epigenetic insights
so for methylation of a sample
and we can also do host research
um for with generating whole genome
libraries from as little as one nanogram
with our swift sonic 2s library prep
thank you for listening to this webinar
um
i hope you learned something and please
get in contact if you have
any questions or would like to learn
more
thank you